The breaking of the fourth wall has been
defined as a character acknowledging the
existence of the audience outside of the
film.
But besides merely recognizing the
existence of the separate reality,
Martin Scorsese,
shutter island actually invites the
audience to completely identify with its
main character by placing the camera
inside a mirror,
a the,
uh.
Now what's remarkable about this shot is
that it helps you clarify why
consecutive viewings of shutter island
changed the experience of the film
completely.
You could even say it at,
it's like you're watching a completely
different film.
We start off by watching and mystery
thriller about you was martial Teddy
Daniels and a search warrant escape
patients from remote Ashlyn mental
institution.
But mostly the story is about his search
for the killer of his wife,
the arsonist and route latus who
supposedly also a patient on the island.
As the story unravels,
we find out that the two marshals
might've become the victim of a blog by
Ashley through sinus and from revealing
dark secrets about the institution.
And it's only you had to climbing.
So the story that we discovered a real
truth,
you're name is andrew latest.
The 67th patient had dash cliff is you
andrew?
No.
I suspect most of yours were shocked by
this plot twist and with the evidence
laid out and it's equal,
might have fought and how did I not see
this before?
However,
some people continue to deny teddy's
true identity seeding that Ashlyn is in
fact a sort of of naziesque CIA lab of
some kind.
So clear up some of these
misunderstandings.
I will argue that the fourth wall newer
shot is key to comprehending the truth
behind shutter island and how to fill
manages to make audiences turn a blind
eye towards reality.
Where are the kids?
It's important to note that the rector
of Martin Scorsese stated in an
interview that the entire movie takes
place inside of Teddy's head.
Notice that there's not a single scene
that doesn't depict teddy as the focal
point of the story or even as seen
without his mere presence.
On top of that,
the audience is constantly reminded of
the tragic goodness of Andrew's made up.
Karen.
None an exactly square with teddy.
Danielle's the man,
the legend that give you that
Teddy's profession as a US marshall and
his role as protector of justice also
give his character superiority over to
seemingly untrustworthy doctors of ash
cliff,
and if that wasn't enough for the
audience to aligned with Teddy,
he's also revealed to be a war hero
having liberated victims of the
Holocaust from a Nazi concentration camp
and from the get go.
It is obvious what's Teddy's
preconceptions about the Asheville if
institution are
same,
something like that before.
Both the framing and a dramatic,
almost menacing music playing in the
background attitude unparalleled at this
facility might not be any less evil than
the infamous Nazi death camps.
It's a real tragedy about his characters
that he cannot come to terms with the
death of his and suffers from a massive
amount of guilt for having executed a
number of cam guards during the war.
Teddy's really shown to be a victim
rather than a perpetrator and all of
this really makes it difficult for the
audience not to fully aligned with the
protagonist and really end up being just
as delusional as the main character
himself.
Andrew,
please do.
However,
even during the first viewing of the
film,
you can already notice that Teddy's
world is a little strange.
Many of the characters don't really seem
to act as one would expect them to in
certain situations.
The guards seem to be irrationally on
Agis steadying chuck arrive and that's
supposedly because of the escape
patient,
but later shown to be bored.
When ted,
he launches a search party on the
island.
Patients are waving and looking at
setting,
but not a chuck and doctors and nurses
are kind of laughing at Teddy's attempts
to interviewed him.
Very impression defense mechanisms.
Even chuck eggs out of character as he
struggles to get his firearm out of his
belt.
Just seems like an odd thing to happen
to you.
As Marshall and especially for film,
it's a bit emphasis on such a subtle and
arguably insignificant occurrence and
even said he shows irrational behavior
as he starts to act on impulse and
becomes increasingly violent and
reckless in a search for a man who looks
almost too fantastical to be real.
Then there's the fact that the film has
a number of continuity errors that are
so obvious that they kind of possibly,
you haven't missed buddy editor on
accident.
In one scene,
the character pretends to drink water
out of a nonexisting glass only for the
glass,
so your peer empty in the next shot.
These jump cuts enhance the feeling that
said he's living in a sort of dreamlike
state.
Hence why both the character and
audience start to question the realness
of the protagonists world.
However,
all of this can still be explained with
the argument.
That's the entire thing.
It was just a set up and said he was
just being drugged and manipulated into
believing that he is in fact the
perpetrator himself.
Why are you here?
I killed my wife.
Now there's really one scene or rather
one musical piece that quite subtly
manages to debunk this train of thought
called tip top caroline and string.
It ain't mine.
Besides the fact that the music
parallels the general feeling of the
scene.
Courtside for strings and piano and a
minor by Gustav Mahler remains a rat or
odd choice of music to say the least
receipt at the music triggers a response
in Teddy to brings him back to the
headquarters with the Dachau
concentration camp.
We're just seeing music was playing on a
record player.
Now why is this odd?
Because Khrushchev Mahler was Jewish and
his music was subsequently banned by the
Nazis.
Secondly,
the quartet for strings belongs to malls
earlier and lesser known work.
So why on earth would a s s chem water
and a half this exact piece playing in
his headquarters?
It seems highly unlikely that this event
actually happened and it makes us wonder
about the reality of Teddy's memories.
The music adds a sort of grimm brothers'
fairy till like quality to the memory.
Well,
snow was falling everywhere and bodies
life frozen on the ground.
The thing is real life footage shows
that there was no real snow to be seen
during the liberation of the camp.
Adding further doubt about just how
trustworthy you teddy's perspective is.
A little research also reveals the
Mahler actually never finished a quartet
and had trouble finding his own voice
leaving in fragmented and isolated in
between his work.
The parallel of Andrew Dan seems obvious
as he struggles to find his own voice
and hides behind the voice of Teddy
taking the ferry back in the morning,
come on show,
and to prove that Andrew is in fact
hiding behind this fake persona.
We only have to look at the opening
scene of the movie.
After Teddy froze up,
he looks into the mirror,
which in film often indicates that the
character has a split personality on top
of that,
and you can see that half of this phase
is illuminated by the sun,
whereas the other half is left in the
dark,
signifying teddy's buried real
personality even unknowingly states his
main goals,
the entire story.
This theme returns multiple times and
comes to climates when Andrew's face
fully illuminated and is finally
accepted reality as it is.
Or when did you notice that little
bandaid on his forehead?
Now that's gone here to indicating that
he is no longer covering up his wounded
personality.
Oh,
I remember that part where chuck is
praising Daddy.
Notice that the legend also explains
that Teddy's personality is not real,
but just a made up story.
But the most important theme of all to
be found in the opening scene is a
substance that both literally and
figuratively keeps us seen a float
water.
So at the end of the story is revealed
at Andrew's wife drown to children in
the lake and it's wide.
Teddy's so nauseated by water and like
psychological practice steady.
You're slowly but surely put an
increasing contact with water until he
ultimately comes as close to a strauma
as possible by diving into the sea.
But Teddy's physical appearance and
demeanor also changed dramatically
during the film.
He starts his journey with a rat or
collected and no nonsense attitude
towards the world.
But as the story progressed,
as he slowly stripped from the things
that make him who he is versus gun,
then his clothes,
then his attitude and ultimately his
entire made up self.
As I stated earlier,
Andrew came up with Teddy's persona only
because he was unable to deal with the
violence and guilt that he's had to
endure in his life.
This sort of cyclical nature of violence
and cruelty that is part of humanity and
in which he actively pursue because what
ultimately drove andrew into insanity,
no matter how much he denies it away.
Thanks for harmless,
but you can be controlled,
but I know,
oh,
we've known each other for centuries.
I also notice that the sadistic water
isn't named on purpose because wharton
is an Anagram for Andrew and there are
more of these anagrams to be found as is
shown by Dr Kali at the climax of the
story,
don't we?
Phil Sue explained to name of Teddy's
faith partner chuck all who turns out
it's speed mysterious.
Dr Nian couldn't tell the US Marshall's
office,
but that he's a defense mechanism.
Surprise mother fucker because
fanatically chuck all sounds a lot like
chuckle,
which in turn indicates his character's
rule is jester or trickster.
Within the realm of story as a whole.
The side of companion characters are
known for their miss chief and their
motivation to push to protagonist
interchange and that only does chuck
trick teddy into believing that he is
his partner,
but he also has an active interest in
helping Andrew to accept reality as it
is.
Nice.
Makes me one.
Yeah.
WHATSAPP,
which would be worse.
Live is a monster and a day is a good
man and to me this is the magic and
brilliance of shutter island.
It knows it's burgers and making the
audience identify fully with a fake
character and arguably manages to make
us just as delusional as Andrew himself.
On top of that,
it gives us a fascinating look into the
psychology of this tragic character
trauma and the nature of reality.
It shows us just how powerful our minds
can be and the perspective really is
everything because when we fully aligned
with the point of view or a certain
belief,
we sometimes feel to see the truth even
if it's laid out right in front of her
eyes.
Switch light.
All right.
Thank you guys so much for watching,
man.
This really was a long ass video,
but,
uh,
I hope it paid off for you in the end.
If it did,
please don't forget to leave a like,
comment,
subscribe and especially shared this
video wherever you can.
Uh,
because that's the way we get our voice
out and introduced many more people to
our content.
Thank you all again so much for your
support so far.
Don't forget to follow,
wasn't social media and we'll see you
guys in the next one.